we're hopping in the car together and we
are gonna search the city late night
pizza it's surprisingly difficult to
find delicious late-night food in Los
Angeles tonight I'm meeting up with a
fellow night owl to explore the
restaurants that many say is an
exception to this rule are you tired I
am hungry I'm like so ready for pizza
right now you grew up in these coasts
how would you compare Pizza on these
coasts if he's on the west coast so far
I believe that the water tastes
different pizza here so clean cut that
it's like almost it's like - it's a
worry I'm not gonna lie I am optimistic
about tonight though we are going to a
place called timorous Pizza it is open
till 4:00 in the morning it's the most
late night eats in oh hey I'm Joe Damari
founder of de Moraes pizza we've been
here for 31 years
dough is made in the morning it's rolled
into little balls and put in plastic
bags and we unbag it as we use it so
every pizza is made fresh except for the
slice pies they're 80% cooked and then
put in a rack and then when someone
orders it we continue cooking it the
other 20% as opposed to reheating it
it's like a fresh pie we grew up on
these guys and we've had trouble finding
great beats on the west coast why do you
think that is the facts is the water the
water has to be from Maine to New Jersey
is far west of Chicago if you go south
of New Jersey or west of Chicago you
rapidly lose the minerals that are
conducive to making a kind of bread
dough bagel dough you talk about the New
York bagels so for the first 25 years in
business I
the water from lost and I couldn't keep
bringing the water from Boston and the
flour from Italy so I filled the rest of
the container with Italian water and now
I also bring the tomatoes and the olive
oil makes the flavor even so much better
tell us why you decided that this
restaurant is open till 4:00 in the
morning when the bars closed they come
out at 2 o'clock looking for food so we
figured okay we'll stay till 2:30 we
stayed till 2:30 but then all of a
sudden waitresses and waiters are coming
and they have to clean up before they
leave then all of a sudden get all these
deliveries who wants Pizza 3:30 4:00 in
the morning I found out I found out
hence now 10 years later we're open till
4:00 in the morning every night we're in
the market for three slices tonight
what would you our most popular yeah
what would be the three three
recommendations well you know still the
cheese pizza is the most popular pizza
in the world our most popular pizza that
has meat on it is our combo but our most
popular pizza is called the pizza Bianca
it's fresh spinach and roasted peppers
sauteed in olive oil and fresh garlic
chopped wood parmesan mozzarella and
ricotta cheese well we are looking
forward to trying okay oh man super for
sure yes let's do this oh yeah we're
serving cheese it's hot oh my goodness
this is the East Coast beats are these
guys pizza this is awesome the crust is
just like a perfect texture crunchy but
it still has that like danger that
you're talking about that you like this
is a perfect balance fantastic it's like
Boardwalk pizza
I think pizza that you get down the
shore yeah what a nice weekend do you
write music while you're touring as well
especially when like we have runs like
this we're just out for days at a time I
have a lot of time to like simmer are
the future acts
yeah I went on a date with a girl in
Japan she takes me to this place where
they put maple syrup on pizza okay and
it's really it's amazing oh this is
solid as lights out good I mean there's
just so much flavor going on with these
toppings and so fresh great balance of
like Sophos and crispness well I got a
question for you you're 21
yeah and could you kind of walk us
through how slushie came to be I've been
producing music for like a while and my
soundcloud got deleted all the copyright
strikes hit at the same time there was
no getting it back and I was just like
dude this is it that was like my
livelihood quote unquote you know I
built that over like three four years I
made the slushie logo and like a night
it was just like a last-ditch effort
might as well do it right
restart with all the knowledge that I
have now then just kind of went for it
don't need extra cheese for this no no
that's game we'll be right there let's
take it back an important part of your
story is the way we used to have the
life you have now yeah tell us a little
bit about your past and what you were
going through and and how your outlet
helped you so I wasn't necessarily like
the most popular guy in school I didn't
really talk to anybody I have Asperger's
I was a lot slower socially in the
beginning of high school as a result of
that I would kind of isolate myself and
one thing that really helped me was was
music so like listening to music writing
songs once I actually started to write
more and more I kind of realized that
like I shouldn't really care what people
think about you know me that really set
things off for who I am now I really
don't care what anybody thinks you know
look at my hair you know I don't care if
there was one clear goal from the entire
slushie project is it's just doesn't
matter where you come from what you look
like what you sound like as long as you
have a dream then you keep driving that
home then you can do it it's possible
I've gotten proof of that I'm just a
blue haired guy from Jersey where three
slices deep which to you has been your
favorite slice the combo for sure I'm in
the combo bo2 I'm not even like a like
an olive fan at all or mushrooms I'm
like just the way it was put together it
all blends together seamlessly
you don't feel gross operated either
would you come back here this is my new
spot fit your needs both ever well we
appreciate you sharing the day and the
night with us and hoping we see each
other good yeah that's that I'll be over
here
thanks for having me yeah thank you so
much my tour bus is not here but I will
hail an uber or craft rectified one of
those scooters